what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation I am about to do a first time watching
for a movie that has been at the top of my
list for months now just haven't found quite
the right time to do it then I saw that they
are doing an adaptation of I think the Broadway
musical version so I thought like oh now is
the time to do some SEO game here and finally
watch a movie that has literally been the
first title I see out of all these movies
I haven't watched yet and that is the color
purple I've heard good things about it I've
heard Whoopi Goldberg is great in it despite
whatever Twitter controversy she's always
in I've heard of that uh Oprah is also great
in it Steven Spielberg movie um but I've never
seen a moving frame of it once in my life
and for a ride it's like two and a half hours
long hope it's a good one so the ladies and
gentlemen if you could leave a like I know
you can that'd be very much appreciated also
uh subscribe and click that notification Bell
we are covering so many movies on this channel
happy to have you along the journey to become
part of the reject Nation as always full-length
and watch along is where you single with your
own copy of The Color Purple I am watching
this off of Max today uh is available for
our super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
we cover a whole bunch of stuff exclusively
over there as well with reaction highlights
and watch Longs included let's get into the
swing of things people
[Music]
Earth conditions in this time this weather
you better not never tell nobody but God you'll
kill your Mama wait what let's get rid of
the baby I got two children but my daddy a
baby boy called Adam he took while sleeping
and a baby girl called Olivia that's my wife's
name I don't think he killed my little baby
boy I heard he sold it to a preacher and his
wife just sold the baby he come home with
a girl from around a town called gray she'd
be almost my age but they can't marry now
my little sister Nettie she's got a man always
looking at her damn young Danny Glover he
got three children though he seen Ned in church
and I every Sunday evening Here Come mister
Tammy he'll be smiling I'm so used to associating
him from Lethal Weapon get old is anyhow she
want to marry first that sucks she ain't fresh
though but I expect you know that you're spoiled
twice oh let me see you again
turn around
what's he doing that for your sister's thinking
about marriage bass tank lover seems like
a real creep I don't cry I lived there thinking
about Nettie and then I think about that pretty
woman in the picture I know what he doing
to me he died to her and maybe she like it
really disturbing surprise this is PG-13 is
this just about this woman surviving this
very abusive lifestyle maybe it's my preconceived
notion because I'm familiar with Schindler's
List that I wasn't expecting this to have
a bit of a Hollywood gloss to it feels less
raw Spielberg and more Robert zimecus I think
[Music]
Jesus Danny Glover's definitely the villain
of this movie other than the general world
I'm gonna make me and my little girl a new
dress come out louder would you like yes now
run away is she my baby her name Olivia Pauline
well but I call her Olivia what so definitely
is Olivia oh unless it's just a massive coincidence
just
left so I call her old Olivia wow this is
really sad
because the Candy stay with us for a spell
oh
god what happened with you and Paul I just
couldn't keep him off me you gotta fight got
all I know how to do is stay alive that's
what she's gonna learn in this story
it's a beautiful shot finding light in the
Darkness
you are nailing it yo these two little girls
are great I gotta go to school no
oh my God
[Music] damn this [__] is so horrifying
[Music] oh my God
oh that's so mean [Music]
these little girls are like so good come on
girl cause I'm waiting for you
you cut me and I'll kill you man just go right
for the slice cut his third and run [Music]
man his offspring must be terrible I think
another place is sort of like a taunting boyish
bully don't let me get ready yeah
what's up huh yes okay nothing's really changed
huh
she says she right but she never right she
said only death could keep her from it maybe
she did oh so she hasn't heard from her in
this entire time
oh [__] Sophia Sophia Sophia that's Oprah
I'm living with him with her husband and they
say I can live with him for the rest of my
life hell yeah oh I love her humble don't
you move One Step just don't make me wait
too long Harpo Papa
oh Harpo I won't I will I will I do [Laughter]
you mean now salute the bride [Applause] [Music]
[Laughter] well I guess we don't have to worry
about Harpo being like his dad unless this
movie proves me way wrong
do it better than a good sound beaten Sophia
thinks too much of herself needs to be taken
down a pig or two ask Harpo what I'm gonna
do about Sophia
oh she just breaks my heart man damn Ita whoa
you told Harpo to beat me it wasn't Mew
out of Northfield and the mule just went crazy
he started kicking
oh my life are here to fight I never thought
I had to fight in my own house
Sophia beat on Harper then Harper beat on
Sofia and then one day Sophia she just can't
take it no more good good for
oh the woman that should have been your Mammy
should Avery the hell is going on I need to
see our eyes then my feet can let go of the
spot they stuck in you show is ugly jeez everyone's
so goddamn meaner in the in the cooler on
the Shelf ain't warm enough how you work the
stove huh yeah they become a real adult huh
assistant this this cruel narcissistic prick
nicely done very good job
scared of her
I just stand back and I wait to see what the
wall gonna look like
who exactly is this shook person who you silly
man you ain't well mind your own goddamn business
I feel just fine just had to eat has she not
left this room yo Paul love you my boss still
love me except you don't know it
some real fascinating subject matter in this
he is so much taller than him just couldn't
rest till you got her in your house could
you dancer it really does play like a little
boy huh my own Daddy won't even have nothing
to do with him oh Mr talking trash about sugar
folks don't like nobody being too proud or
Too free
slowly standing up I love Chuck Avery you're
all our children's got different daddies oh
she'll Gabriel's children got the same Daddy
I can voucher for nothing silly you as my
sympathy
little bit of satisfaction foreign after he
leave the field he knocking down and piling
things up sometimes his friends Swain come
by to help Lawrence Fishman hey hobo hey
[Music] it's pretty cool you could build it
[Music] she just sees a lot of women that
she wishes she could be like huh
that's all I'm about to sing is called Mercedes
Blues what because she scratches out my head
when I was healing
oh all eyes on her I did not see this coming
[Music]
too [Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
we sure ain't got a whole lot of times
[Music]
is feeling fine
this whole movie no it wasn't Power Rangers
so nice [__] humiliating this [__]
out of Albert too if everyone knows what's
up
[Laughter]
I believe I want me some of this here I want
to introduce y'all to my friend Henry broad
next that Albert guy is so pathetic
[Music]
I love her to dispatch she's so good
she best to leave you alone is it magic John
you said someone get a main dance with his
wife if it wants to never officially filed
for divorce you're just a bigger like I said
talking to the raw woman like that man with
me
oh no
Lord have mercified oh hell yeah only one
developing a relationship with sugar Avery
[Laughter]
for me to go what you beat me when you ain't
here why you do that you beat me for not being
you oh all right that's some truth you still
love me I got what you call passion for do
you mind if I ever sleep with me you like
sleeping with him just climb on top of me
do his business let me see what you sound
like he going to the toilet on you he does
the ball his [__] on her don't nobody
love me I love you you think that's ugly no
I don't I think you beautiful
oh [__] what's going on am I late to pick
it up on some cues here I think I'm late to
pick it up on some cues here
foreign
woman there's like so much pain even in her
Smile and now she's on The View always getting
in trouble
is that her paw I couldn't sleep at night
I was wondering why
Jesus mean man the men in this movie suck
I'ma go with her this is my only chance to
break from Mr jail
what you doing how's he always sneak up on
her way
oh my God
I was gonna miss you too Miss Seeley Chicago
jeez Ed
so can you give me some sugar
would you like to work for me hell no what
did you say hell no what did she say she said
hell no what did you say to miss Millie I
said hell oh hell no
oh
[Music] after many years they let Sophia out
of jail just to put in the next wow she ended
up being Miss Millie made after all may have
bought Miss Miller a new car and she don't
answer fear to teach her how to drive it wow
Mr Hamilton nice to see you I hope you folks
have a nice Christmas this year well thank
you very much
have you ever thought about going to Mars
wow so it's not as abusive but she still seems
insufferable I'm gonna drive you home tomorrow
I God
oh boy hi my name is Emma I'm very pleased
to meet you
I'm just gonna only let her have a day
[Music]
cause I don't know y'all no more oh
I can do it I can put this thing in reverse
and I can make it go the right way
woman stop driving man
oh that's my sister so that's a squeeze in
I don't know her either these adults false
sense of care [__]
man that is messed up I've heard so much about
you feels like we all friends
her husband this is my husband yikes [Music]
come on Miss Haley go upstairs with me okay
I gotta finish stuff in the turkey has her
sister been riding this whole time
I've been writing to you over the years but
I Albert said you'd never hear from me again
and since I never heard from you all this
time I guess he was right wow Albert oh you
deserve to be castrated one thing I want you
to know I love you and I'm not dead man it's
been so many years the lady you met in town
is named Corrine they could not have chillins
and then they say God sent them Olivia oh
and Adam ah they say they stayed together
the children huh and now God has sent me to
watch over them to Lavish all the love I feel
for you on them wow it's pretty crazy
and your sister
good morning go find them letters
oh [__] she'd really be taking a stand
right now
foreign
wow he really buried the [__] out of this
[Music] goddamn right I wrote a letter to
you almost every day on this ship on my first
side of the Africa Coast wow that he seems
like she led a much better life do you know
what a jungle is trees they are so big they
look like they were built confines and Ferns
and animals
wow she's really getting to use her imagination
why can't Tashi come to school she asked me
the olinca don't believe in educating girls
she said they're like white people at home
who don't want black people to learn after
two months all we hear is chopping and scraping
and dragging one of the boys in my afternoon
class burst out as he entered the road approaches
the road approaches what a crazy production
every Hut that lay in the proposed road path
was leveled our church our school my heart
all went down in a matter of hours I guess
it's not that much better sweet Corey dad
from fever and grief oh my goodness just pray
[Music]
don't keep me waiting for their joy and escapism
comes from reading these letters man honey
come out here for you to take all day to shave
me and get the molasses out your ass oh my
God just cut his throat that's crazy so is
it like like reading the letters living through
the stories of her sister will be her final
push to her surely standing up for herself
and getting her freedom
out of here
all right
put your head back my neck itching like the
inside of a horse's ass [Music]
[Music] foreign
good peoples huh Celia is coming with us [__]
yeah Over My Dead Body that's what you want
now what's wrong with you you low down dirty
dog oh what
oh [__] this is really happening
you knew she was the only somebody in the
world who loved me
hell yeah my kids they coming home soon we
all get together we gonna sit around and whoop
your ass
y'all was writing kids made my life here hell
of course your daddy ain't nothing but some
dead horse [__]
on the life of the man foreign
[Laughter]
thing you've done for me
I was feeling real down I was feeling mighty
bad
I know day is a God goddamn one penny in my
money did I ever ask you for anything I never
asked you for nothing not even your sorry
ass hand in marriage
[Laughter] Uncle [__] you going where
I kept going on riding this house pass me
them people oh God this is so good all you
fit to do is be Shields made and you ain't
even that good of a cook anyway ain't nobody
crazy enough to marry you do that is such
a prick any more lettuce come could be
you're poor you're ugly you're a woman you're
nothing at all did you do right by me everything
you even think about gonna fail goddamn right
it's been a pleasure meeting all of you the
dare you plan for me is the one you gonna
rot in
whoa everything you've done to me already
done to you
all she had to do was raise her hand up against
him
I'm here I'm here
God damn it she gets us here sister and her
children [Music]
all the Shadows
foreign [Music]
has passed
look how withered to the house not even the
mailbox can be kept together
can't even shave come on it's time to go now
go home come on time to go now time to go
I'm just gonna roll over and die it sure is
nice see you too together again
okay so you have any character here first
he's just really drunk my mama married this
dead man two years after my real daddy dad
you as well and he died on top of me oh it's
all yours now your real daddy on this land
and he left it to your mama and when your
mama died it passed on to you and your sister
Nettie
I'll very much explained [Music]
what
I think it pisses God off if he walked by
The Color Purple in a field and don't notice
it okay it just won't be loved like a say
in the Bible everything want to be loved interesting
that's why it's the color purple it's the
theme you
oh
oh so sister what a cool spot yeah [Music]
yeah be to me
fascinating [Music]
oh
everyone congregating [Music]
that's pretty cool
[Applause] [Music] yeah how fun
come on make amends for Christ's sake
daddy Sinners have soul too
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] oh that's she
coming home [Music]
is he about to do the right thing
two people lost away
that's right the immigration stuff in Africa
[Music] damn
[Music] it's the same actress this looks like
the same teenage actress
and they're running through the purple she's
doused in purple
this is your son
he says this is the day of his dream
this is Olivia mama
[Music]
come back I'm very attached
yeah he did it right by her
oh
foreign [Music] Ty used to go by Larry Fishburn
alrighty well I could talk for like nine minutes
because apparently a trailer just came out
uh or like an hour ago while I was filming
this and um it's one of the big ones so I
gotta hop on it you might be able to match
it with whatever this video gets released
with that trailer with the way I'm looking
right now I thought this was a really moving
film very very moving I'm not familiar with
the time um that this took place in but I
thought it was for the most part a smart film
I thought for the most part it was poignant
uh very touching I mean look first thing I
gotta talk about like the performances all
right Whoopi Goldberg was phenomenal in this
movie phenomenal and it's pretty crazy I think
what one of the Testaments to how strong the
performances are in this film is like I'm
so familiar with the Oprah Winfrey personality
I'm so familiar with the Whoopi Goldberg personality
they like she's become like a host you know
and viewed as like a comedian Whoopi Goldberg
and then you have Oprah who's freaking Oprah
she's Oprah Winfrey and all I saw the whole
time when watching this were these two characters
Whoopi Goldberg's transformation from this
abused timid victim who evolves into someone
of true strength finding the strength within
herself and watching this Evolution over time
like I really believe this time span that
they did Oprah Winfrey Sophia is just it's
like like the phrase that comes to mind for
me is she is like a force of nature I thought
she was so strong so powerful and then you
know you have someone like uh Danny Glover
who's I've seen him in other works obviously
outside of the Lethal Weapon movies I made
a comment about it you know Predator 2 villain
and witness he's not a bunch of films I haven't
quite seen him do a role like this though
uh this guy was evil and cruel early on in
it I did say like he kind of reminds me of
like a boyish bully like someone who's like
a boy in a man's body and then to see that
that is exactly who his character was by the
time you meet the dad he is he is this person
who is taking out a lot of his own traumas
like there's a lot about the commentary on
you know not just like the the systematic
racism that is within the the world that they
grow up in but a lot of these uh traits of
upbringing especially the toxic traits of
upbringing especially than the men that I
wasn't expecting to be explored I didn't know
what to expect my only preconceived notion
was that I I heard it was like a a touching
picture and it was Steven Spielberg so that
was interesting white guy directing it hmm
wonder if nowadays you can get away with that
doesn't matter Steven Spielberg he's a phenomenal
director I guess the thing that kind of threw
me for a loop that it took me a bit of adjusting
towards was a bit of like the Hollywood gloss
Sheen that's sort of placed over it I kind
of just assumed because it's Spielberg and
then knowing that this might be a bit of a
like rough experience based on the kind of
commentary and subject matter that I heard
hints about that it would feel a little bit
more like like a raw gut punch real and while
there were a lot of scenes that really deliver
that especially especially because due to
the very very strong acting uh there there
were aspects of its filmmaking that I you
could feel a bit of that PG-13 touch versus
going for like that hard R rating that uh
that this would have done but I have to transport
myself to the time in which movie was made
which on IMDb it says uh 1985 so if this is
coming out in 1985 I know this is like a film
that's considered a classic so I can imagine
that in 85 this this is a little bit stronger
a little more brutal like nowadays I think
if you were to do I mean other than the version
if we were to do like this story today it
executed not the Broadway musical version
that I I think that's what the the new movie
is going to be an adaptation of but to just
do something that's based on the book I feel
like nowadays in the 2020s you would want
it to be uh something that feels a lot more
raw not to say this movie does not have that
gravitas of realism laced throughout it uh
there was a somewhere in that cross between
because I finally I just saw Gone With The
Win For the First Time It's not nothing like
gone with the win but it was still kind of
captured in that that area that era with capturing
that like that Wonder because that's the the
odd part to me the dichotomy of capturing
this subject matter yet um it still feels
like it was made with a sense of love I still
feel like there was so much care and a passion
to the filmmaking behind it that even though
at times that the tone and overall execution
didn't click for me specifically in the first
third of the movie as the movie started to
really progress in the last two thirds you
know really it was around the time when shook
Avery came into the picture uh oh Margaret
Avery is the is the actress and her last name
is also Avery Margaret Avery also phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal I thought there was
some Unique Kind of relationships that I haven't
quite seen done in any movies especially the
ones that they draw between uh Celie and Suge
that I thought was very powerful as well I
think there's a lot of great powerful moments
in here and even for like the character of
Albert to have an unexpected Arc I thought
they were just gonna end it off on him being
like full-on villainous and for him to even
have a realization which is you know part
of it is seeing who these people really are
underneath the surface and letting that part
of their soul shine through and then even
instantly a bit of like that joyous hope and
optimism at the very end I did find uh quite
fitting actually so yeah I could see why this
movie has been able to it's not just this
movie but the story has been able to overall
stand the test of time there's a lot of resonating
themes in here I think to this day I mean
it's from 85 I thought it was a 90s movie
The cinematography is still very much excellent
the production values are Rock Solid I loved
of the way all this was overall like captured
uh even at times if the tone overall didn't
quite click for me but then at times it did
work I was surprised by how they had these
humorous angles in here at times it would
feel like it was Sometimes undercutting some
of the tension or the or the the rawness of
it where I could imagine especially in like
85 like oh this is kind of a brave story to
be told and it feels very authentic but I
guess watching it through today's lens at
times it would sort of feel like it it might
undercut a moment or two but then at the same
time you know for a movie that does have all
these things that are like emotionally and
physically abusive in life even sometimes
in the Harsh Times there is still a sense
of humor to be captured overall action I'm
like you know what having some of that humor
because at times it did really make me laugh
and a lot of times the humor did just shine
through with the characters it still worked
for me I could hear someone at the door and
they're just gonna have to wait that's someone
being John I would need to process it a tad
bit more there's so many things about it that
do feel personal and there's a lot of things
like dealing with like cultural grievance
as well at times uh the melodramaticness some
of the things that could feel a little bit
more sappier self-indulgent when it could
have gone a little bit more subtle because
yeah it's two and a half hours long and I
didn't actually feel the run time when I was
watching it and obviously there were some
moments that definitely brought me to tears
uh I think there's a lot of great I I don't
know if I quantify this movie for me personally
as this is a great film from beginning to
end but there's so many like just great powerful
scenes that are laced throughout there's some
just so many strong things and I I would I
guess I did kind of crave it to be a little
bit more a little bit more feeling in the
Raw real thing but I I also blame myself for
thinking that because I that was the one thing
I expected uh from it just knowing that it
was like Spielberg and some of the other films
that he's done but then I'm like oh but this
might have been one of the from knowing the
films with that Spielberg was working on at
that time in like 1985. this might have been
his first Venture into making a movie like
this like after E.T at Indiana Jones you know
this is like his first attempt before like
94 when he got around to like Schindler's
List and you know and then doing like Saving
Private Ryan things that did go a lot more
for that raw gut punch uh but for the most
part I think the the effort and the performance
is all around like I think just for the performances
alone it's it's worth watching there's still
a lot of strong stories with some gut-wrenching
scenes but overall a story that has a lot
of beautiful angles to it and a survival tale
as well like there's there's so many things
that they're dealing with uh all in once and
I think it's a it's for the most part a fluid
character exploration parts of the execution
shouldn't feel dated but the movie still feels
Timeless if that makes sense so yeah overall
I still think the directing was really good
not just capturing the time I forget what
city they live in but not just capturing the
societal time of that but also implementing
uh the the African culture we've been throughout
just this journey of of Whoopi Goldberg's
uh Sealy growing growing into this human being
over Time Left Me overall with an emotional
impact overall I left very satisfied uh and
man those performances are so freaking strong
I was surprised by that I was I was so surprised
by like wow this this really holds up and
also another thing I give it to for for a
moment of this length I do think the editing
is actually really really strong as well like
you have to really calculate how you're going
to do this so that way it doesn't feel like
it's dragging or Meandering and I actually
think that they did an excellent job at pacing
this movie so while at times a little bit
too much of a gloss a lot times a little too
self-indulgent and sappy uh for the most part
though I never faulted the actors for that
it was more so some of more the hollywood-isms
behind it the performances the direction the
the storytelling there are a lot of Brave
qualities to what they decided to do with
this giant bag of a lot of different themes
they are uh unpacking all at once but overall
I did leave very much satisfied and still
very much impressed by a lot that happened
in this film so I'm glad I finally watched
it but guys what do you think about the color
purple do you love it is it one of your faves
I'd still put it in that category of of those
kind of there it does have that feeling of
like the forest that's why I said zemek is
like Forrest Gump or like Amazon like Shawshank
Redemption around there but if I think if
this was willing to be R-rated it could have
been just that much better for me but yeah
thanks nice sentimental time alrighty well
thank you guys for watching and uh I will
catch you all soon [Music]